[Música]
bienvenidos a reporteros el magazine de
los grandes reportajes en la redacción
de france 24
hoy los llevaremos a costa rica
costa rica es un país muy pequeño
ubicado en centroamérica que alberga el
6% de la biodiversidad global y desde
hace varios años se ha convertido
gradualmente en un laboratorio mundial
para la descarbonización es el único
país tropical que ha conseguido revertir
el proceso de deforestación
tanto que ha duplicado su cobertura
forestal en los últimos 30 años para así
cubrir la mitad de su superficie
terrestre con árboles alrededor de una
cuarta parte de las zonas terrestres se
ha convertido en áreas protegidas o
reservas el resultado es que la nación
es un sumidero de carbono y un gran
atractivo para los turistas la
electricidad ya proviene en un 99 por
ciento de fuentes renovables
principalmente
hidroeléctrica pero también eólica solar
y geotérmica
la transición energética puede ser más
fácil cuando se es un país pequeño pero
costa rica está sentando un precedente
creador y audaz para las grandes
potencias que cuentan con medios
económicos mucho mayores para lograr sus
objetivos climáticos el área en la que
aún tiene un gran desafío al país es la
descarbonización del sector transporte
el cual genera 40 por ciento de las
emisiones totales
pese a ello costa rica se sigue
posicionando como un líder ambiental
global a continuación el reportaje de
nuestros corresponsales laurance
cuvillier y mateo coman
[Música]
sueña con un país en el que la ecología
está en primera línea donde los bosques
han estado recuperando terreno cada año
durante décadas costa rica- menos del
0,1 por ciento de la superficie
terrestre pero un concentrado de ideas
verdes los llevaremos allí en un auto
eléctrico por supuesto
primera parada curridabat en las afueras
de la capital san josé
aquí nació el concepto de ciudad dulce
es decir una ciudad que absorbe co2 del
que produce
agarro un puñado de cosas en exceso de
agua
la consigna del municipio regeneración
los residentes aprenden a enriquecer
naturalmente el suelo para cultivar su
propio huerto o participar en
actividades de reforestación urbana la
ciudad cultivar a sus propios árboles en
este gran invernadero en construcción
esto nace porque hay una necesidad de
contar con material vegetal que sea
nativo verdad porque lo que encontraste
en los viveros normalmente es exótico y
viene de otros lugares como de asia y
áfrica verdad entonces ahora venimos con
otra fase que es bueno terminar de la
construcción de este invernadero y este
vivero y después ir a buscar las plantas
madres al bosque
lorena estudió agronomía pero en una
época en la que se dependía de los
fertilizantes y los pesticidas para
producir más ha vuelto a aprender los
fundamentos de la agricultura
regenerativa a través de las puertas nos
hemos conocido nosotros
y tenemos estos proyectos tan bonitos
que nos pasan ocupado todo el tiempo su
jardín está ahora repleto de especies
tropicales
galvanizadas por el a uno casero esta
compañera no la donó la municipalidad de
curridabat
y nos dio un curso para que
aprendiéramos a usarlo además en
curridabat hay ahora 100 parques para 65
mil habitantes el río que atraviesa la
ciudad se ha convertido en un corredor
biológico
para que la fauna vuelva a florecer
ciudad dulce es una visión de mundo y
esa visión de mundo la tratamos de
desagregar en una visión de ciudad se
trata de volver a darle el espacio que
se merece por ejemplo el río aquí nos
pasa un un riachuelo poder decirle
también a todas las especies nativas que
antes estaban en la ciudad y que por el
desarrollo urbanístico en algún momento
se fueron y poderles decir bueno aquí
está su espacio está muy recuperando
espacio para ustedes para tener una
convivencia entre entre todos nosotros
pero esta visión no nació ayer la
protección del medio ambiente forma
parte de la historia del país desde 1949
cuando se fundó el hice la compañía
eléctrica estatal aunque en aquel
momento no se mencionaban los gases de
efecto invernadero ni el cambio
climático
y ya hablaba del uso sensato de los
recursos naturales una apuesta que ha
puesto a costa rica en la senda de las
energías renovables desde que surgieron
así que lógicamente en septiembre de
2019 el presidente de costa rica carlos
alvarado recibió el máximo
reconocimiento de naciones unidas a la
acción medioambiental el premio
campeones de la tierra
estas recompensas coherente con nuestra
herencia
es coherente con lo que las generaciones
de nuestros padres y abuelos quedaron
para costa rica por costa rica
en la actualidad del 99 por ciento de la
electricidad de costa rica está
descarbonizada el país tiene capacidad
para generar el doble de la demanda
nacional cerca del 8 por ciento de esta
electricidad se genera aquí la represa
de reventazón una central que ha sido
citada muchas veces como ejemplo de
buenas prácticas ambientales y sociales
la fauna acuática tiene su propio paso
protegido de los generadores y el cauce
del río no certera en el caudal
ambiental que es lo que vemos aquí es lo
que garantiza que podamos continuar con
las actividades de rafting navegación
pesca aguas abajo de la represa
estas británicas inversiones fueron
posibles gracias a otra peculiaridad
local costa rica no tiene ejército se
suprimió en 1948
y su presupuesto se reorientó hacia la
educación la sanidad y las
infraestructuras
la planificación en la clave nosotros
tenemos
70 años de construir esta matriz
renovable donde hemos ido balanceando
las diferentes fuentes somos muy
afortunados en en agua en volcanes y en
viento todavía tenemos un potencial muy
grande en solar que no hemos
desarrollado y esta electricidad se
encuentra en estas estaciones de recarga
al lado de la carretera hay 70 en el
país con acceso libre suficientes para
cubrir el territorio sin problema este
usuario descubre cómo funcionan
lo primero es conectar el conector es
decir que y después pasas la tarjeta
aquí abajo te va a decir tarjeta
autorizada hasta que también te autoriza
ya debería el empezar hasta la segunda
semana la tercera vez que lo cargo esta
resina de recién lo acabamos de adquirir
el vehículo el gasto en gasolina al ver
lo que no he pagado semana a semana ya
rondando los 150 mil colones casi 300
dólares la verdad es que es bastante
ahorro para mi cuenta esta es la recarga
actualmente es gratis en costa rica
circulan 2.000 vehículos eléctricos
aproximadamente el 1 por ciento del
parque automovilístico sigue siendo poco
pero es el único sector de la industria
del automóvil cuyas ventas no cayeron
durante la pantalla estamos ayudando al
planeta y costa rica especialmente que
es un país que genera energía eléctrica
pues sale muy cómodo la reducción del
65% en el impuesto sobre vehículos
extensión de las restricciones del
tráfico se hace todo lo posible para que
esta opción sea atractiva mientras el
parque automovilístico sigue siendo una
gran sombra en el panorama del
rendimiento ecológico la región de la
capital san jose
alberga un tercio de la población del
país y el tráfico está constantemente
condicionado pero el futuro de la
movilidad eléctrica parece prometedor
las desventajas que tienen otros países
al ser tan grandes es que necesita
acción al vez muy muy grande nosotros
con un vehículo de 200 kilómetros de
autonomía que es un vehículo de hace dos
años podéis bien recorrer de san jose
el caribe de san josé al pacífico y
disfrutar de las playas que son tan
bellas bonitas playas o sí y una
naturaleza exuberante los llevamos a la
selva tropical hasta donde alcanza la
vista no todos son bosques primarios
como se podría pensar
muchos de ellos nacieron de un esfuerzo
nacional de reforestación en 1980 los
bosques cubrían el 20% del territorio
costarricense y hoy el 55%
este set es el que alquila esos
preciosos coches eléctricos llegamos a
mccain keiko es un lugar espectacular y
miembro de la ucr incio de como círculo
verde y lleva unos 15 años trabajando en
el sector del ecoturismo su agencia
ofrece experiencias totalmente
ecológicas
alquiler de coches eléctricos y reservas
aquí por ejemplo
[Música]
experiencias de inmersión en la selva en
contacto con la fauna no hay aire
acondicionado no hay televisores tampoco
hay cortadoras de césped y los alimentos
son producidos localmente él se hizo
amigo de eduardo que ha puesto en marcha
un negocio hotelero ecológico con sus
seis hijos un pequeño ritual de
bienvenida se exprime un jugo de caña
fresco eduardo solo tenía 10 años cuando
llegó aquí su familia era pionera en la
selva la montaña o la tierra era libre
nadie tenía dueño cuando eso hace 63
años
entonces las fincas la gente de acogida
lo que quisiera 500 hectáreas la
carne era de la montaña porque los
animales de la montaña habían muchos
animales en la montaña saínos de pez
cuentes chancho de monte cariblancos ya
los años empezaron había gente que no lo
mataban animales sólo para comer sino
que para venderlos entonces entonces
fueron escaseando mucho
entonces fue la historia de un
renacimiento lugar donde el bosque casi
había desaparecido en una generación los
muchachos me dijeron papá aquí no no
cortamos más árboles no hay que cortar
más árboles porque vamos a trabajar en
turismo y el turismo le gusta el turista
extranjero más que pero le gusta la
montaña papi no hay que volver a matar
serpientes de aquí porque porque las
serpientes a los turistas les gusta la
serpiente
la gran explotación ganadera de la
familia se ha transformado en una
cornucopia ecológica al principio por
ejemplo fue difícil porque nosotros
veíamos al turista como como un
extraterrestre
en los amigos de él dejaron también eran
cazadores y por ser amistades y ver por
ejemplo con nosotros acabamos provecho
más del bosque teniéndolo en pie o
cuidando los animales en turismo ellos
comenzaron a adoptar la misma costumbre
una agricultura diversificada integrada
en el paisaje tropical
este tipo de maíz es
cultivado y consumido localmente uno de
los pilares de este nuevo tipo de
turismo el turismo tiene que reflejar la
esencia de este país y la esencia es la
naturaleza la sostenibilidad y parece
tener un efecto real en los visitantes
nunca habíamos visto un país así con
tanta naturaleza y vida salvaje
es impresionante no lo esperábamos
en costa rica un tercio de la tierra
está protegida
el país forma parte de la colisión de
alta ambición climática que abogará en
ako 26 por un objetivo recomendado por
la ciencia proteger el 30 por ciento de
la tierra y los océanos del mundo esto
no solo absorbería grandes cantidades de
carbono sino que también le generaría la
biodiversidad
y nuestra forma de explicar la
diferencia entre costa rica y muchos
otros países tiene que tiene jungla que
tiene bosque primaria es la cantidad de
fauna que encuentras en este país en los
foros internacionales costa rica también
es una voz poderosa que representa a los
países en desarrollo que son víctimas
del cambio climático
todos los años en centroamérica
los huracanes devastadores matan a
cientos de personas destruyen
infraestructuras y cultivos
luego viene en periodos de sequía
extrema que arrojan a miles de
agricultores a las rutas de migración
en la próxima con el ministro de
medioambiente combinará propuestas
ambiciosas con los puños necesarios
sobre la mesa entonces cada evento de
estos gigantes es un golpe enorme a las
finanzas públicas hay que volver a sacar
hay que volver a reconstruir y además es
con deuda y sigo pidiendo más plata para
volver a reconstruir es un círculo
realmente
muy
muy poco justo al final son los países
que están recibiendo los efectos de este
modelo carbono intensivo hay una
dinámica que siento que colectivamente y
como humanidad tenemos que romper
en una américa latina que aún no ha
tomado medidas contra el cambio
climático costa rica se ha adelantado a
todos en el camino de la regeneración
ecológica dejamos atrás nuestro fiel
coche eléctrico y nos vamos de este
pequeño país convencidos de que tiene
grandes ideas que ofrecer
hasta aquí reporteros de la semana
recuerde que para sintonizar este y los
programas anteriores puede ingresar a
nuestra página web france24 puntocom
hasta la próxima
[Música]